[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débat grève mondiale pour
le climat marche pour le climat ou
encore no plastique challenge face à
l'urgence climatique les initiatives
pour prendre soin de notre planète et
mythifie saint quentin en yvelines a par
exemple la semaine du développement
durable bat son plein ces actions sont
elles utiles les citoyens peuvent-ils se
sauver la terre c'est le thème du débat
du jour en plateau j'accueille bertrand
ou lyon bonsoir genre vous êtes et vice
président chargé du développement
durable et de la ruralité au sein de
saint quentin en yvelines vous êtes
également le maire de magny les hameaux
en face de vous sébastien mêlée bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes chargé de mission
énergie climat au sein de alex qui alors
alex et l' agence locale de l'énergie et
du climat merci en tout cas à tous les
deux d'avoir accepté l'invitation juste
avant de démarrer un mot sur la lèque
alors je crois que vous existez depuis
2000 ans quelles sont vos missions
tout avait donc là l'est qu'on fait
partie déjà d'un réseau dallest qui en a
une quarantaine en france qui sont
fédérées ensemble et qui ont à peu près
tout les mêmes missions une alec c'est
une association qui est créé à
l'initiative des collectivités pour
l'accompagner et pour accompagner plus
largement l'ensemble des citoyens et des
acteurs d'un territoire donc les
collectivités collectivités
territoriales les communes les
entreprises les citoyens aussi sur
toutes les thématiques relatives à
l'énergie à la transition énergétique en
fait l'énergie habitat les déchets là
c'est la pollution émissions de gaz à
effet de serre etc
on parlera évidemment plus précisément
au cours de cette émission justement de
vos différentes
l action mais je vous propose tout de
suite d'entrer dans le vif du sujet avec
tout d'abord un chiffre selon un rapport
du groupe d'experts intergouvernemental
sur l'évolution du climat le seuil de
1,5 degré de réchauffement sera franchi
entre 2030 et 2050 de alors pour faire
simple si nous ne changeons pas notre
mode de vie
dans la décennie qui arrivent les
conséquences environnementales seront à
catastrophique bertrand orion est ce
qu'il n'est pas finalement déjà trop
tard pour agir
il faut jamais se dire qu'il est trop
tard mais il faut agir et plus on avance
plus on prend beaucoup de retard
quand on voit aujourd'hui 2030-2050 2030
pour me donner la situation c'est le
moment où la ligne 18 du métro du grand
paris express passerait à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines éventuellement
voilà donc c'est quand même on est sur
des sur des échéances qui sont qui sont
assez courtes et aujourd'hui il faut à
la fois qu'on fasse tout pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique et
aussi à la fois qu'on fasse tout pour
pouvoir adapter au mieux nous adapter au
mieux aux changements qu'il y aura tout
de même quelle est la stratégie
justement de saint quentin en yvelines
sur cette thématique
la stratégie de nos territoires a été
d'abord de mettre en place un plan
climat air énergie même si auparavant il
avait un agenda 21 et d'autres actions
mais en termes de développement durable
ce plan climat air énergie doit nous
permettre par un certain nombre
d'actions concrètes de mener justement
cette bataille en terme de rénovation
énergétique de bâtiments par exemple
puisqu'on a un fort un fort enjeu dans
ce cadre là à saint quentin en yvelines
également en termes de transport
puisqu'on a également un fort enjeu dans
ce cadre là au niveau de saint quentin
en yvelines tout est parti d'un
diagnostic qui a été établie notamment
par par l'agencé aps a classé vert qui
est vraiment un partenaire essentiel
pour pour notre territoire ce soit pour
les particuliers ou la collectivité de
saint quentin et les communes et à
partir de ce diagnostic donc on a
partagé un certain nombre d'actions
envisagées sur les prochaines années
tous ensemble ça concerne des actions de
nos collectivités communes et interco
mais aussi des actions des entreprises
et des actions des particuliers c'est
sur une plateforme un esquimau alors
tout est sur une plate forme
collaborative qui s'appelle esquimaux et
tout le monde peut à la fois donner son
avis sur des actions qui sont envisagées
mais aussi en proposer d'autres au fur
et à mesure l'objectif est vraiment que
tout le monde puisse partager tout ça
c'est s'est pas uniquement les citoyens
à titre personnel en fait je dois faire
des choses c'est pas comme ça qu'on
arrivera à sauver la planète c'est à la
fois les collectivités qui ont des
moyens
en terme d'aménagement en termes de de
rénovation de bâtiments en termes de
politique de transport c'est aussi les
entreprises puisqu'elles ont un certain
nombre de bâtiments et notamment sur sur
50 ans du vide mais aussi en termes de
finalement de capacité à se transformer
à être durable au niveau environnemental
et au niveau social et puis aussi bas
forcément au niveau des particulièrement
bourdonner sébastien bounet ce que vous
avez à l'impression que les saint
quentinois puis même plus largement les
citoyens ont conscience de cette urgence
climatique
une partie oui en tout cas
indéniablement il ya cette marche pour
le climat le témoigne ici et quand même
il ya quand même des d envie de faire
quelque chose d'attractif sur cette
thématique là après tout les saint
quentinois je ne sais pas ce que vous
avez vu au sein d'al est qu'une
évolution peut-être justement des
mentalités des personnes justement qui
est menée avec tu ne veux voir tout à
fait dernières années où on touche
qu'elle plusieurs milliers de personnes
chaque année et notamment on le voit à
travers des défis comporte des défis qui
porte sur des écogestes uniquement donc
engagé aucun moyen financier qui sont
faciles à réaliser
souvent conviviaux parce qu'ils sont
partagés et les pertes par exemple les
bases dans la lumière ont coupé les
robinets
quand on n'est pas en train de les
utiliser pour le brossage des dents par
exemple le pull plutôt que le degré sur
le radiateur pour se chauffer enfin il y
a
il ya pléthore de petits gestes et donc
de plus en plus de citoyens finalement
pour ces petits gestes finalement qu'ils
peuvent a sauvé du coup on en a tous les
ans un peu plus et puis ceux qui sont
venus pour un défi s'engage sur un
deuxième défi est ensuite revient de
voir l'espace info énergie pour des
conseils sur la rénovation de leur
logement
vous avez parlé de la marche pour le
climat y en aurait une justement à 50
ans
yvelines ce samedi c'est également
aujourd'hui le début d'une eau plate
stick challenge celle des chips en
plastique
ce vendredi c'est également la grève
mondiale pour le climat
finalement il ya pas un petit peu trop
d'action pour le climat finalement aussi
père où c'est nécessaire finalement ces
différentes actions
je pense que c'est nécessaire maintenant
il faut que derrière aussi ça amène
certaines actions concrètes et certains
engagements concrets
encore une fois c'est pas le citoyen
tout seul qui va réussir à sauver les
choses
je prends l'exemple puisque vous évoquez
le plastique je prends l'exemple de tout
ce qui est des chais et notamment
plastique très simplement nous on peut
nous dire il faut trier
il faut faire attention nous
culpabiliser aussi par rapport à tout ça
et nous faire payer finalement le
traitement de ces déchets mais à côté de
ça l'emballage il a bien été créé
quelque part et ce quelque part c'est
pas le citoyen qu'il l'a créé et cette
habitude de marketing d'emballage de
suremballage qu'on connaît dans beaucoup
de nos supermarchés notamment
il faut que ça s'arrête et là dessus il
ya plusieurs solutions soit les les
entreprises qui en ont la responsabilité
le fond d'elle-même
soit les citoyens doivent se prendre en
main pour refuser tout ça soit en allant
sur des consommations alternative soit
tout simplement en ramenant les déchets
qui sont dans ses magasins aujourd'hui
il faut vraiment que tout le monde ait
conscience de de la problématique dans
laquelle on est et c'est pas uniquement
les citoyens qui sont aujourd'hui
justement j'ai de faire des matches pro
clima des des actions du coup plus
virulente que ce qu'on pourrait que ce
qu'on pourrait imaginer c'est c'est pas
comme ça qu'on va y arriver à un moment
et c'est dommage d'en arriver là il ya
la semaine européenne du développement
durable qui va se dérouler du 30 mai au
5 juin saint quentin en yvelines a pris
un petit peu d'avancé il y avait
notamment le week-end dernier un village
climat voisins le bretonneux quelle est
l'utilité cette manifestation puisque je
sais que la lèque étaient présents
notamment pour soulager climat oui
voit les images mais présent sur surtout
les tous les villages climat où tous les
événements de ce type qui peut se
dérouler sur le territoire c'est déjà
une occasion de se faire connaître de
montrer aussi des choses concrètes
on fait beaucoup de projets concrets au
niveau de la halle est qu'on incite les
citoyens et en particulier des saint
quentinois à s'engager dans des actions
concrètes concrète c'est l'occasion dé
montrer sur ses stands de de partager
aussi avec d'autres acteurs qui sont
présents également sur toutes les
thématiques les déchets la protection de
la biodiversité
on voit qu'il ya vraiment tout
l'éventail des possibilités d action en
a pour tous les goûts
c'est un bon moyen de connaître tout ce
qui peut se faire et puis on va
s'engager aussi sur les thématiques qui
nous plaisent le plus avant évidemment
d'arriver aux autres à la semaine
européenne du développement durable dure
une semaine pourquoi avoir fait ce choix
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de la faire
durer trois semaines pour pouvoir
s'adapter aux différents calendriers et
on est sur une image de l'agglomération
oui on est sur une agglomération avec
douze communes avec aussi des programmes
communaux d'actions et il faut pouvoir
tout simplement être présent partout le
plus possible et si on a été fixé sur un
vidéaste climat d'une seule journée on
pourrait pas être au plus près des
habitants
ces villages climat sont partout
vraiment important vous vous évoquiez
les actions concrètes de l'alec où on a
on a travaillé sur une thermographie de
l'ensemble des bâtiments par exemple de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines thermographie
qui a été qui a été réalisé il ya
quelques mois
aujourd'hui c'est la lettre qui
accompagne les habitants pour pouvoir
expliquer cette thermographie pour
pouvoir éventuellement faire des
compléments aussi de d'études sur sur
leurs bâtiments et pour pouvoir les
accompagner pour trouver les meilleures
solutions pour faire la rénovation
énergétique de leur bâtiment dans les
villages climat c'est cette explication
là qui est donné sur le tri des déchets
l'agglomération a proposé la diffusion
de
deux composteurs et puis il ya ce tri
qui doit être content et qui doit qu'on
doit continuer d'expliquer de manière
récurrente
c'est là dessus aussi que les services
de l'agglomération interviennent
directement sur ces villages climat au
plus près des habitants
alors ces patients mais les parlé tout à
l'heure de geste s'il n'y avait qu'un
seul geste à faire pour que tout le
monde fasse pour sauver la planète ce
serait quoi selon vous un geste ce geste
c'est un peu compliqué mais entre il y
en a deux sur lesquels la titre perso je
me suis engagé et je vois la complexité
qu'il y à là dessus c'est d'utiliser le
moins possible mon véhicule particulier
et le deuxième c'est de ne plus avoir
d'emballage un geste s'il fallait
retenir un geste déjà j'ai eu ma réponse
toute faite c'est réfléchir au bon sens
c'est déjà des questions de base est ce
que j'en ai vraiment besoin
est ce qu'il n'ya pas plus simples
souvent parce que le bon geste est
souvent aussi le geste le plus simple le
plus pertinent le plus efficient
chaque moment de la journée différents
moments de la vie mais on parlait de la
voiture est ce que j'ai besoin d'aller
prendre la voiture pour prendre perdre
du temps à démarrer
faire le tour du pâté de maison me garer
et le chemin inverse alors que en trois
minutes dû suer pied en l'émission
touche bientôt à sa fin on va commencer
à à conclure alors justement face à
l'urgence climatique
est ce que les citoyens peuvent sauver
notre planète oui mais pas tout seul
c'est tout le monde en fait le citoyen
ou qu'ils soient qu'ils soient citoyens
qu'ils soient habitants qui soit en
entreprise qui soit élu tout le monde va
participer va devoir participer et c'est
nécessaire parce que c'est des choses
qui se construisent ensemble ces envois
un futur ce futur il faut le construire
ensemble déjà et après
les pistes et les moyens sont
aujourd'hui nombreux on a énormément
d'initiatives qu'elle vienne des
collectivités qu'elles viennent des
start up qu'elle vienne du monde
associatif ou même des citoyens qui
partagent de plus en plus leurs bonnes
idées et plein de choses nous on essaie
de les valoriser notamment avec le
concours - économe qui redémarre cette
année pour la troisième édition
cela peut présenter des rénovations qui
soit intéressante on a les défis zéro
déchet qui va repartir en septembre
aussi pour sa porte bien son nom zéro
déchet est arrivé voilà on accompagne on
est un outil une alex est avant tout un
outil est donc c'est tout il faut
l'utiliser en fait s'il est là il est à
disposition gratuitement des habitants
des acteurs du territoire
il est aussi à disposition des
collectivités faut pas hésiter à s'en
saisir
les retrouvailles ont trente secondes
pour conclure après on doit quoi sauver
mais pas si je verrai nouvelle société
et donc construire une nouvelle société
c'est finalement tout l'ensemble du
tissu de notre société
la base c'est le les citoyens puisque
finalement construit entrepreneurs élus
ou habitants on est citoyen avant tout
et c'est cette nouvelle société que doit
réussir à construire ensemble une
société qui qui se réalise pas sur l'eau
de l'environnement mais qui le fait
finalement totalement en bonne harmonie
etc c'est un enjeu fondamental pour
qu'on puisse tout simplement vivre et
vivre ensemble puisque les premières
victimes de tout ça ce seront les
personnes qui sont aujourd'hui les plus
en difficulté au niveau social merci en
tout cas tous les deux d'avoir été à
présent ce soir là c'est la fin de cette
émission
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve à
mercredi prochain pour un nouveau cette
nuit de débat
[Musique]
où